>> DO YOU THINK THERE'S ANY
CREDENCE TO THE PRESIDENT'S
CLAIM THAT YOU BROKE THE LAWS
RELEASING THE MEMOS?
>> NO.
I THINK HE'S MAKING STUFF UP.
>> Laura: THE UP RETURNED FIRE
ON "FOX AND FRIENDS."
>> COMEY IS A LEAKER AND A LIAR.
HE LEAKED CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
TO GET A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
HE'S GUILTY OF CRIMES.
IF WE HAD A JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
DOING THEIR JOB --
>> Laura: AND IN HIS FOX NEWS
INTERVIEW WITH BRET BAIER, COMEY
RESPONDED TO TRUMP'S
ACCUSATIONS.
>> HE'S JUST WRONG.
FACTS REALLY DO MATTER.
THAT'S WHY I'M ON THE SHOW.
THE MEMO IS UNCLASSIFIED.
IT'S IN MY BACK.
THE FBI CLEARED THAT BOOK BEFORE
IT COULD BE PUBLISHED.
IT'S A FALSE STATEMENT.
>> Laura: LET'S SEPARATE FACT
FROM FICTION WITH OUR PANEL.
JIM JORDAN AND BYRON YORK,
RICHARD GOODSTEIN, A FORMER
ADVISER TO PRESIDENT CLINTON.
I WANT TO PLAY PART OF THIS
INTERVIEW TONIGHT WHERE BRETT
ASKED ABOUT THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION AND THE
COMPARISON.
LET'S WATCH.
>> YOU CAN SEE THE DISPARITY
WHERE PEOPLE LOOK AT THE CLINTON
CASE AND HOW THE TRUMP CASE IS
HANDLED.
>> I DON'T SEE DISPARITY THOUGH.
>> THERE IS A DISPARITY.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE IT.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT WRONG.
HE'S NOT MAKING THINGS UP.
HE'S NOT MAKING UP THE FACT THAT
THEY CALLED SHERYL MILLS --
>> Laura: SHERYL MILLS WAS --
>> CLINTON'S LAWYER AND HER
CHIEF OF STAFF AND THE SUBJECT
OF THE INVESTIGATION WHEN THE
CLINTON INVESTIGATION STARTED.
COMPARE THAT TO THE IDEA THAT
THE PRESIDENT'S PERSONAL LAWYER
GETS HIS DOOR KICKED IN AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE UNITED
STATES I DON'T EVEN THINK WAS
CONSULTED.
IT WAS RUN OUTSIDE OF THE
UMBRELLA OF THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION, THE MUELLER
SPECIAL COUNSEL INVESTIGATION.
YOU DON'T TAKE TO THE HIGHEST
OFFICERS IN THE LAND WHEN YOU
KICK IN THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYER'S
DOOR?
OF COURSE THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
BE UNSET AND MORE IMPORTANTLY,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE UPSET.
>> BYRON, THERE WAS A MOMENT
THAT THEY DISCUSSED WHO FUNDED
THE DOSSIER.
YOU'VE BEEN WRITING ABOUT THIS.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WHEN DID YOU LEARN THAT THE
DNC AND HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN
FUNDED CHRISTOPHER STEELE'S
WORK?
>> I STILL DON'T KNOW THAT FOR A
FACT.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> I ONLY SAW IT IN THE MEDIA.
I KNEW IT WAS FUNDED FIRST BY
REPUBLICANS --
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> I'M SORRY?
THE DOSSIER WAS FOUNDED BY THE
REPUBLICANS?
DO YOU WANT TO KNOW WHO IT WAS
FUNDED BY?
>> I WANTED TO KNOW WHO I KNEW.
IT WAS FUNDED BY PEOPLE
POLITICALLY OPPOSED TO DONALD
TRUMP.
WHICH PARTICULAR OPPONENTS
WASN'T IMPORTANT TO ME.
>> THIS WAS A STUNNING MOMENT.
HE SHOWED APPARENT IGNORANCE OF
THE BASIC FACTS OF THE DOSSIER,
WHICH IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS IN THE WHOLE
TRUMP --
>> Laura: WHY?
IT WAS THE MAIN BASIS FOR THE
APPLICATION TO SPY ON CARTER
PAGE.
>> AND THAT'S ALSO WHAT COMEY
AND THE OTHER INTEL CHIEFS
BRIEFED PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP ON
ON JANUARY 26, 2017 STARTING THE
WHOLE FIGHT BETWEEN TRUMP AND
COMEY.
IT'S A HUGELY IMPORTANT
DOCUMENT.
TALKING POINT THAT IT BEGAN WITH
REPUBLICANS.
WE KNOW -- ANYBODY HAS FOLLOWED
KNOWS THAT THE FUSION GPS
RESEARCH INTO TRUMP'S BUSINESS
LIFE BEGAN WITH REPUBLICANS.
THEY QUIT THAT.
THEN THE STEELE DOSSIER WAS
FUNDED BY DEMOCRATS.
>> Laura: ISN'T THAT SHOCKING?
YOU'VE SOLD 600,000 BOOKS, WHICH
IS AMAZING.
YOU WROTE A BOOK ABOUT THIS.
YOU'RE ON BRET BAIER'S SHOW.
OH, IT'S WHAT I READ IN THE
MEDIA.
YOU WERE FBI DIRECTOR.
YOU USED THIS DOCUMENT.
RICHARD, I'M SORRY, BUT THAT DID
STRIKE ME AS QUITE A STUNNER.
>> IF I CAN, CONGRESS MADE
REFERENCE TO SHERYL MILLS,
HILLARY CLINTON'S LAWYER.
DONALD TRUMP WHO SAID ON AIR
FORCE ONE, CALL MY LAWYER,
MICHAEL COHEN.
FAMOUSLY SAID DURING THE
CAMPAIGN, IF YOU TAKE THE FIFTH,
IT'S BECAUSE YOUR GUILTY.
THAT'S WHAT MOB PEOPLE DO.
MILLS NEVER TOOK THE FIFTH
NOBODY IN THE CLINTONS TOOK THE
FIFTH OTHER THAN THE ONE GUY --
>> Laura: YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
TAKE THE FIFTH.
THEY GAVE HER IMMUNITY.
>> THEY COULD HAVE GIVEN ANYBODY
THEY WANTED --
>> Laura: WHY DID THEY GIVE HER
IMMUNITY?
>> THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS,
THE SUGGESTION THERE'S A
COMPARISON BETWEEN THE TWO.
CARTER PAGE IS ONE OF FIVE
FOREIGN POLICY ADVISERS THAT
DONALD TRUMP NAMED AND THE
FBI -- HE WAS A FOREIGN AGENT.
EXCUSE ME.
THAT IS NOTHING LIKE WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
DONALD TRUMP WENT INTO THE OVAL
OFFICE AND GAVE RUSSIANS SECRETS
ABOUT THE ISRAELIS BEING
EMBEDDED AND WAYS IN WHICH THE
ISLAMIC TERRORISTS --
>> Laura: WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR THAT IS
ON THIS NETWORK TONIGHT THAT
MADE COMMENTS THAT WERE -- A RUN
OF THE MIDDLE PUNDIT ON ANY
CABLE NETWORK WOULD KNOW THE
ANSWERS TO, WHICH I FOUND
UNBELIEVABLE.
I WANT TO PLAY ANOTHER SOUND
BITE.
THIS IS ON THE FISA APPLICATION
ITSELF.
BYRON, YOU'VE WROTE ABOUT THIS.
CONGRESSMAN, YOU'VE BEEN
DISSECTING THIS.
LET'S WATCH.
>> CALL THE DOSSIER UNVERIFIED,
SALACIOUS.
WHY DID YOU USE THAT TO THE FISA
COURT TO ASK FOR SURVEILLANCE
FOR CARTER PAGE?
YOU LED WITH IT, A BULK OF THE
FISA APPLICATION DEALS WITH THAT
DOSSIER.
WHY?
>> THAT'S NOT MY RECOLLECTION,
BRET.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THE FISA
APPLICATION HAS BEEN RELEASED.
>> THERE WAS A LOT MORE THAN THE
DOSSIER IN THE FISA APPLICATION?
>> MY RECOLLECTION THERE WAS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME ABOUT
PAGE AND WHY THERE WAS PROBABLE
CAUSE THAT HE WAS AN AGENT.
>> IS THAT TRUE?
>> NO.
WHEN YOU LEAD WITH IT, THAT'S
YOUR PRIMARY EVIDENCE --
>> Laura: HAVE YOU SEEN THE
ENTIRE FISA APPLICATION?
>> WE HAVE NOT.
>> Laura: WHY?
>> THEY WON'T LET US.
I ASKED CHRISTOPHER WRAY.
THEY WON'T SHOW US.
>> Laura: WOW.
>> THEY DIDN'T TELL THE COURT
WHO PAID FOR IT.
THEY DIDN'T TELL THE COURT THAT
THE AUTHOR OF THE DOCUMENT,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, HAD HIS
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE FBI
TERMINATED.
THEY DIDN'T TELL THE COURT THAT.
WHEN WE GO TO THE COURT, WE HAVE
TO TELL THEM THE WHOLE TRUTH.
THEY DIDN'T TO THAT.
>> REMEMBER THE HOUSE INTEL
FOUND OUT THAT THE DOSSIER WAS
THE BULK OF IT AND SEPARATELY
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
ALSO FOUND OUT THAT IT WAS THE
BULK OF IT.
>> Laura: HE ALSO SAID HE DIDN'T
SEE ANY BIAS IN THE PAGE-STRZOK
TEXT WHEN THEY TALKED ABOUT THE
INSURANCE POLICY.
THEY WERE CLEARLY NOT WILD ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP.
EVEN THAT'S BEEN SAID ON OTHER
NETWORKS.
BUT HE DIDN'T SEE ANY BIAS.
>> AGAIN, THERE WERE REPUBLICANS
ON THIS NETWORK AND OTHERS THAT
WERE SAYING THE SAME THING ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP DURING THE 2016
CAMPAIGN THAT STRZOK WAS.
STRZOK WAS SAYING THE SAME
THINGS --
>> Laura: BUT NOT INVESTIGATING
HIM.
>> HE WAS SAYING THE SAME THING
ABOUT ERIC HOLDER.
THEY WERE DISHING DIRT OR
TRASHING EVERYBODY THEY COULD.
SO TO SUGGEST -- STRZOK WAS A
PERSON THAT SUGGESTED THAT COMEY
DO THE LETTER THAT BASICALLY WAS
THE BEGINNING OF THE END FOR
HILLARY CLINTON.
I DON'T THINK --
>> IT WASN'T BIAS.
IT WAS ANIMUS TOWARDS THE
PRESIDENT.
PETER STRZOK IS THE DEPUTY HEAD
OF COUNTER INTELLIGENCE.
HE'S BEEN DEMOTED AND REASSIGNED
FOR HIS BEHAVIOR.
>> Laura: THE COLUMBIA LAW
PROFESSOR TO WHOM COMEY GAVE
THAT -- THOSE MEMOS, TWO OF THE
SIX MEMOS AND HE BASICALLY
INSTRUCTED HIM TO GET THEM OUT
THERE.
NOW WE FIND OUT, WHICH WE DIDN'T
KNOW, MAYBE YOU KNEW THIS, THAT
HE WAS ACTUALLY A SPECIAL
CONSULTANT TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT?
AND WE NOW FIND OUT THAT HE'S
NOW OPERATING AS COMEY'S
ATTORNEY.
>> HIS LAWYER.
>> Laura: IS THAT RELEVANT?
GIVES YOU ATTORNEY CLIENT
PRIVILEGE --
>> IT HELPS TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
HE DID TO GET THE MEMOS OUT.
IT WAS A STUNNING RE-LATION.
COMEY DOES NOT CONSIDER WHAT HE
DID LEAKING.
HE HAS REDEFINED LEAKING TO MEAN
ONLY DISCLOSES CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
HE BELIEVES -- HE'S SAID SEVERAL
TIMES THAT HE DIDN'T LEAK WHEN
HE GAVE THIS MEMO TO DAN RICHMAN
FOR THE PURPOSE OF RICHMAN
TELLING THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
ABOUT IT.
COMEY MAINTAINS THAT THIS WAS
NOT A LEAK.
HE ALSO SAID IT COULDN'T HAVE
BEEN A LEAK BECAUSE HE LEFT THE
FBI AND WAS NO LONGER A
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE.
>> GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS WROTE A
BOOK ABOUT CONVERSATIONS WITH
BILL CLINTON.
SCOTT McCLELLAND BROKE A BOOK --
>> AFTER THEY WERE OUT OF
OFFICE.
>> THAT'S THE CASE.
THAT COMEY WAS OUT OF OFFICE AND
HE WAS NO MORE OF A LEAKER THAN
GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS OR Mc
GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS OR M
McCLELLAND WAS.
>> THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT KEPT
THEM AS IF THEY WERE STATE
SECRETS.
FEW MEMBERS WERE ALLOWED TO SEE
THEM.
YOU HAD DO HAVE AN FBI MINDER
WITH THEM.
NO NOTES, NO COPIES.
>> Laura: IT'S CONTRARY TO
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
REGULATIONS --
>> NOBODY ON CAPITOL HILL
BELIEVES THIS IS THE ONLY LEAK
THAT JAMES COMEY DID THERE
RICHMAN.
I MANY GUESS IS THERE WERE TONS.
HE HAD EMPLOYEES WITH THE SGE
STATUS.
I'M GUESSING HE DID LOTS OF